colin kaepernick cashes in on Moke miss
once again crime surges as democrats
focus on blaming everybody else and Don
Lemon explains that black lives matter
doesn't include all black lives I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressive
VPN protect your data from prying eyes
at expressive VPN calm /ban before we
begin I'd like to remind you that if you
have not actually gone to Apple cup
podcast and and left us a review we
would really really appreciate it we are
almost at a hundred thousand five star
reviews on Apple podcasts you're gonna
leave us Arbutus only three stars then
just forget about it and go about your
day but if you're going to leave us a
five star review you've been meaning to
do it for months but you just haven't
had the time make today that magical day
please head on over to Apple podcast a
head over to their app and leave us a
five star view to help us push past that
100 thousand mark okay so this is an
amazing country it truly is an
incredible incredible country
it's an incredible country because
basically you can never underestimate
the power of the American people to make
somebody extraordinarily wealthy if you
are let's say a mediocre quarterback for
the San Francisco 49ers you know
somebody who didn't kneel for the anthem
and who took the Niners to the Super
Bowl is you know good for one season
basically and then you started to fall
apart because people could sort of
figured out your bag of tricks and sort
of figured you out as a quarterback and
soon you found yourself backing up the
immortal Blaine Gabbert
in San Francisco and you're I'm bench
and you started thinking about thing and
soon you were kneeling for the national
anthem while maintaining at the same
time you were not protesting the
American flag or America more deeply you
were really just protesting police
brutality right it's just police protect
that's all it was about is about police
brutality and it turns out that that was
not the most popular thing to do because
people don't like when people kneel for
the national anthem or kneel for the
American flag and also people didn't
quite believe you when you said it was
all about police brutality after all
you're wearing like Marxist t-shirts and
you had socks with pictures of cops as
pigs on them and overall you just didn't
seem like that great a dude the good
news is that in America this racist
hellscape this evil racist hellscape of
america you can make millions of dollars
by calling america and evil racist
hellscape it is the easiest way it is so
so simple
in today's damage you me Robin D'Angelo
and right an awful crap book about how
all of America except for you is filled
with white people or deeply why
premises but you've internalized your
own white supremacy and so you can now
lecture all of us you can be made a
millionaire on the back of diversity
classes you can be Sara au and you can
give lessons to woke white ladies about
how America is evil and they are evil
you can charge them thousands of dollars
for the privilege and you can be Colin
Kaepernick everyone young young kids you
could grow up to be Colin Kaepernick
that's me like quarterback Colin
Kaepernick he's not playing and not to
be like an astronaut you can't grow up
to be like a soldier or the President of
the United States what you can be
everyone can be this you can grow up to
be somebody who makes millions of
dollars of calling America a terrible
horrible evil country you can do it I
dream the dream dream it together you
too can be like Colin Kaepernick I need
to show you this the last two tweets
from Colin Kaepernick on his Twitter
account there are two tweets these are
back to back on Colin Kaepernick's
Twitter account tweet number one comes
out July 4th 2020 quo black people have
been dehumanized brutalized criminalized
and terrorized by America for centuries
and are expected to join your
commemoration of Independence while you
enslaved our ancestors we reject your
celebration of white supremacy and look
forward to liberation for all okay now
let's be quite frank about this Colin
Kaepernick does not seem particularly
victimized in the United States he seems
like he's pretty much enjoying the
fruits of freedom how do I know he's
enjoying the fruits of freedom and
liberation because the very next tweet
on his account quote I am excited for
this partnership with Disney across all
of its platforms to elevate black and
brown directors creators storytellers
and producers I look forward to sharing
culturally impactful and inspiring
projects so what exactly is happening
well capitalism always wins gang and as
soon as you can make a buck off woken us
you'll make a buck off woken us because
Bucks are all that matters
according to ESPN com Colin Kaepernick
will be featured in the exclusive docu
series produced by ESPN films as part of
its first look deal with the Walt Disney
Company the deal between Kaepernick's
production arm ravish and Media and
Disney was announced on Monday the
partnership will focus on telling
scripted and unscripted stories that
explore race social injustice and the
quest for equity it will also provide a
platform to showcase the work of
minority directors and producers I am
excited to announce this historic
partnership with Disney said Kaepernick
despite being exiled from the NFL since
the 2016 season when he took a knee
during
national anthem the protest police
brutality and racial inequality
Kaepernick's still wants to play no he
doesn't Kaepernick has no intention of
ever getting on the field again lies
lies lies can that is just not true
Kaepernick had the opportunity to try
out for teams last year he completely
and purposefully botched it it was
perfectly obvious that that's what he
was doing he has no intention of ever
getting back on the field because now
he's a civil rights leader because as a
man who has suffered deeply from his
race in this country by becoming
extraordinarily rich and powerful off
the back of calling America a racist
telescope he has no intention of playing
in the NFL again come on instead he's
gonna become the face of the Nike
campaign right he's the face of the Nike
campaign 2018 and now he's got the NFL
Commissioner apologizing to him he's got
Roger Goodell saying that he's gonna be
the face of social justice in the NFL
Kaepernick will work closely with the
undefeated which is expanding its
portfolio across Disney to develop
stories from the perspectives of blacks
at black and brown communities his deal
with the Walt Disney Company will extend
across all Disney platforms including
Walt Disney TV ESPN Hulu Pixar and the
undefeated I very much look forward to
the new Pixar movie about Colin
Kaepernick kneeling for the flag before
being before being tackled because he
couldn't make a secondary read during
this unique during this unprecedented
times had Bob Iger Disney's executive
chairman the Walt Disney Company remains
committed to creating diverse and
inclusive content that resonates and
matters
Fallon's experience gives him a unique
perspective on the intersection of
sports culture and race which will
undoubtedly create compelling stories
that will educate enlighten and
entertain and we look forward to working
with him on this important collaboration
the docu-series about Kaepernick's
journey is the first project in
development who will include new
interviews and other never-before-seen
elements as part of the docu-series
who's a producer on the project mel hill
of course Jamel Hill is showing up so
you remember Jamel hello Jamel Hill is a
person who has suggested that everybody
who watches NASCAR is a deep and abiding
racist Jamel Hill is a racial radical
who suggested that America is thoroughly
evil thoroughgoing ly terrible well now
she is working for ESPN Disney too in
that exciting in fact she even tweeted
out about it
very excited I'll be serving as a
producer on Kaepernick's docu-series as
part of his production deal with ESPN
Disney and content collaboration with
the undefeated I consider it an honor to
play any role in telling Collins story
slow clap from America man
for America Eric Hoffer famous cultural
commentator back in the 1960s and 70s he
wrote every great cause begins as a
movement becomes a business and
eventually degenerates into a racket yep
yep and you know what there isn't
there's a little addition that could be
made theoretically okay that that little
addition could be that the amount of
time it takes to get from point A to
point C right there that would be from
from a cause to a racket tells you about
the greatness of the cause
meaning if it's if it's if it's a really
great cause it takes a while
it's go from being a cause to being a
racket because people are actually
motivated to make serious substantive
change a racket is just about making the
box rang Colin Kapernick making the
money and doing docu-series about
himself some the most narcissistic
solipsistic nonsense in the entire world
the quickness with which a movement goes
from being a movement to being a racket
demonstrates the the seriousness of the
of the business of the clause in the
first place listen I do love the fact
that capitalism has now decided has
figured out a way to churn out the
Americas hellscape nonsense for profit
but good for capitalism capitalism is
great at this it does demonstrate also
that corporations it's so funny people
think corporations are right-wing
corporations that are all conservative
they're so conservative and the reason
that you know that corporations are
conservative is because they make money
except for the fact that you don't have
to be conservative to make money in fact
if you are interested only in making
money well one of the things that you
can do is you can just turn out stuff
for the left and that's exactly what is
happening here so everybody is happy to
make a buck off of Colin Kaepernick and
I say good for them I say you know what
as long as we're gonna be stuck in this
morass of stupidity somebody ought to
make some money
and why not Colin Kaepernick hero to the
masses man whoo I mean really what a
martyr he is so how much has he
sacrificed he has sacrificed a backup
slot on the San Francisco 49ers where he
wasn't playing and down because he
sucked so much the Blaine Gabbert was
putting ahead of him he sacrificed that
rich rewarding career for the for the
awfulness of having to trot around
America talking about how evil America
is to be cheers of the and the unnatural
and the unadulterated drooling of the
media to an overall deal with Disney
one of the biggest companies on planet
earth as well as millions of dollars
from Nike to Neal I mean what what a
martyr what a martyr I think when I
think of martyrs I think of like Jesus
Joan of Arc Colin Kapernick I mean like
clearly clearly what a horrible country
this is what a terrible terrible country
it is and if you say it loud enough I'll
pay you to they'll pay you two more
examples of how this has basically
become a business now it's basically
become a scam now and and I'm admit to
being somewhat amused because again half
of the half of the program here is about
how capitalism is evil and capitalism is
terrible and the only solution to all of
this is Marxism and remaking all of
America's systems and the systems of
exploitation are really the problem here
and systemic racism is embedded in
corporate America and corporate America
is like there's a dollar here's a dollar
right here you want any like this talent
you want it and half the woke crowd is
like absolutely I want it bring it right
here for me put it in my wallet I'm
noticing that the that the deep abiding
belief system of Colin Kaepernick and
Jamela Hill has not prohibited them from
taking money from Walt Disney really
what well done everyone
second slip flap of the day already I
mean really just incredibly well done
okay we're gonna get to more more of how
American capitalism can turn anything
can turn any cause into a profit-making
enterprise which is a tribute to
ingenuity it's not a tribute to
forethought because eventually you turn
everything into an industry and then the
industry takes over the business and
wrecks you but at least in the moment
you have to admire the ingenuity of
turning a cause into a racket we'll get
into more of this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that you
might have put on the pandemic 15 and
they even stuck in your house and now
you look down at that waistline and it
has expanded like the testing across the
United States well getting in shape
doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magic
number on the scale it's about building
a healthy habits and feeling better
about yourself and this is where noon
comes in if fitting into the favorite
pair of jeans you're go great but there
are a lot of reasons you might want to
practice self-care every person is
different this is why you need to change
your habits on an individualized
personalized level and Noom can help you
do it noon is a habit changing solution
it helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized forces based in psychology
Noom teaches you why you do the things
you do and then empowers you with the
tools you need to break bad habits and
replace them with
NUMA is one of the biggest most accurate
food databases available that lets you
track meal habits visualize portion
sizes and see calorie density at a
glance chat with your goal specialist in
newman community to get and give and
give help to people we're going through
the same things having that sort of
common community to share is really
great and helps you move forward with
your own health plan you don't have to
change it all in one day and you won't
Remy knew you need to do a day by day
newman gets it small steps make a big
progress sign up for your trial today at
noon that's a no om calm slash appear oh
again that's Noom comm slash Shapiro to
start your trial today n om comm slash
up hero go check them out right now Noom
comm slash Shapiro ok so it's not just a
racket for colin kaepernick obviously
all right Colin Kapernick I mean Al
Sharpton's been making a very lucrative
living for literally decades at this
point from being one of the West's worst
race baiters and a guy who literally
created out of whole cloth an accusation
of rape against a person but there's a
whole diversity industry understand the
diversity industry meaning people who
come into your company and give you
diversity training it's people making
money off dumb ok because they are not
there's there's very little evidence to
prove that this diversity training
actively changes anything inside the
culture of the company understand that
diversity training was basically
designed by corporations to pay off
people not to sue them that's basically
what it was designed to do it was
designed so that companies could point
to their diversity training and then say
how could you say that we have a
systemic problem of discrimination in
the company when we paid we paid Robyn
D'Angelo sixteen thousand dollars to
come and speak at our company and you
say we have a problem with racism we
have a full-on week-long diversity
training that shows we care about
diversity so that's a shield from
litigation you can't suggest that we
have a systemic culture of
discrimination when we are willing to
pay this person who has no bonafide ease
and ever accomplishing anything decent
to come and lecture you about your white
privilege is the City of Seattle is
doing this right now the City of Seattle
has diversity trainers I love that
everything becomes an industry right
it's just it's incredible you think we
can't create jobs in the United States
we can create jobs out of anything
anything it does not matter is that like
that's how Greg cap again I keep
praising capitalism because it's
incredible it's incredible you can take
the worst idea and you can you can turn
it into an entire billion dollar
industry simply by blackmailing
few people with the possibility of
lawsuits and then corporations are like
I don't really want the lawsuit I guess
I'll just toss ten grand at somebody to
come and yell at us about the evils of
white fragility or something right you
can you can do the same thing not just
by threats of lawsuit you can also do it
by threats of boycott you can go after
corporations and you can say to them if
you don't if you don't do X Y or Z and
pay us money well then won't come after
you right this was Al Sharpton's stock
and trade for years I'll shop them and
basically go to corporations and you say
I'm gonna accuse you of racial profiling
Podge a small donation to my National
Action Network will demonstrate your
good faith right this kind of stuff is
super common in the United States so the
City of Seattle is now paying diversity
trainers which is pretty spectacular and
what do they teach so according to
Christopher Truffaut was the
contributing editor of city journal he's
gotten ahold of some of their diversity
documents and they are spectacular
interrupting IRS and whiteness the work
of white accomplices so you have to
practice self-talk that affirms our
complicity and racism right they're
gonna train white people who work for
the City of Seattle to practice
self-talk affirming your complicity in
racism racism is not our fault but we
are responsible you have to do your own
healing work what trauma patterns or
other unwell ways of being are you
complicit in also you have to cultivate
networks of other white people who are
practicing anti-racist accomplice hood
so you can talk through your struggles
in the work of undoing your own
whiteness and showing up as allies and
accomplices I'm not I'm serious this is
all written in the diversity training
also what happens after the thought
exercises it's time to do the work so
what exactly does the work constitute
according to these diversity trainers
the trainer's asked white employees
according to Christopher ovo to quote
let go of comfort guaranteed physical
safety control over the land social
status and relationships with some other
white people then there's a flow chart
that outlines how white people cause
harm to people of color
how do white people keep the system
going well the system coops us through
socialization to cause harm to people of
color and to each other right it's
always the racist systems the race's
systems then you have a mindset and
behaviors that shows that they justify
why we are superior and have been
wronged by people of color then our
anger self-righteousness and
defensiveness masks fear shame and guilt
for the
of our actions then we show up small in
an inauthentic
unable to see opportunities to
contribute as allies and accomplices and
finally when are unable to imagine a way
forward that comes from the place of
humanity and empowerment and the status
quo okay if all this sounds like
absolute drivel that's cuz it's absolute
drivel and the City of Seattle is paying
presumably tens of thousands of dollars
for this cultish nonsense it's all a
racket it is a racket it is not to say
that because of racial sensitivity in
America is a racket it is not this has
nothing to do with racial sensitivity
and everything to do with a group of
people who are making a buck by claiming
that America sucks America is an evil
terrible place where people who stand
for diversity can make tens of thousands
of dollars by talking about how
diversity is really important america's
an evil terrible place and by the way
there are the victims right comment
again colin kaepernick the diversity
trans they're all victims everybody's a
victim amazing amazing stuff also you
can you can be given a you can also even
a slot at the new york times if you if
you demonstrate your own wolken is right
we won't care anything you have to say
but the minute you decide to go woke
then all the sudden we take your opinion
seriously there's a lot of there's a lot
of quan to be made here in the
phraseology of jerry maguire a lot of
quan to be made when it comes to all of
this okay the you shouldn't rest scott
is a the fourth is a journalist
he's also direct descendant of Thomas
Jefferson his piece in the New York
Times today called I'm a direct
descendants of Thomas Jefferson take
down his memorial now no one cared what
this guy had to say five minutes ago
like literally five minutes ago no one
who this guy was her care what he had to
say but now it's time for him to get a
little bit of money so I'm firm to get a
little richer a little more famous cuz
no one knew who he was now it's time for
him to speak out about the evils of
Thomas Jefferson you know a couple
hundred years after Thomas Jefferson's
dead like that now is the time now is
the time we're gonna get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that everyone is moving their work
out from the gym to homes big shot in
the United States that your gym didn't
even open right now that means you have
to find creative ways to use the space
you are in
and it's possible you don't have room
for all the exercise equipment that you
had your gym in fact that is likely in
order you have the money so instead what
you should be doing is looking for
creative ways to work out one of the
best I've found is cross rope Prosser
rope is my new favorite fitness
experience if you're short on time no
worries cross rope lets you get a
killer full-body workout in just at 30
minutes it combines that intense cardio
workout of jumping rope with full-body
resistance training they have a bunch of
different weighted ropes and you can you
can change them up you can put them on
the handles they give you a better a
better feedback which makes it easier
for beginners to get started and learn
they've got durable steel ropes
ergonomic handles a patented fast clip
system for swapping rope ways fast I've
done this workout several times at this
point many times actually and I can tell
you it is a workout I mean it's a
serious workout probably you're but
we're not better than you would be at
the gym anytime and get free access
anytime to quick workouts and fun
challenges with the cross rope app and
now you can pursue your fitness goals
wherever you are even at home it's easy
to get started with cross rope just
order your ropes download the app and
enjoy the results choose between their
get lean or get strong sets depending on
your fitness goals as well or get the
best value for both sets with the Get
Fit bundle so if you're ready for a new
cardio and full-body home workout visit
cross rope comm slash appear isn't just
for boxers and CrossFit athletes who are
jumping rope is for you okay it's a
great workout and it is not hard get up
to 40 bucks off cross rope sets plus
free shipping when you check out today
across rope comm slash appear oh that's
sha Piro cross rope comm slash Shapiro's
go check them out right now hey so again
you can make a lot of waves and gain
publicity by taking the proper local
position these days solution Truscott
who nobody had heard over who nobody
heard of five seconds ago he's a
columnist for salon right so nobody
cared what he had to say but it turns
out that he has a relationship with
Thomas Jefferson because he's direct
descendant of Thomas Jefferson and
therefore he has the authority to say
it's time to take down Thomas Jefferson
Memorial he writes we were surrounded by
the history of Thomas Jefferson when we
would made visits to my grandparents you
drive down to Charlottesville's with our
grandmother to visit our great aunts and
our great grandmother and they would
take us up the mountain to mounts cello
and drop us off to play in the house and
on the grounds they treated Monticello
like it was the family home because in a
way it was
they were great granddaughters of
Jefferson they'd been born and grew up
only a few miles away at a family
plantation called Edge Hill I guess
that's why my brother and I the great
grandsons
took the Jefferson Memorial for granted
we had his ancestral home as a
playground those were all of our great
grandparents and great aunts and great
uncles were buried and where one day we
were told we would be buried too we
didn't need the Jefferson Memorial
Monticello was enough it's still enough
in fact it's a memorial to Jefferson
it's almost perfect and that is why his
Memorial in Washington should be taken
down and replaced described
the National Park Service's a shrine to
freedom it is anything but okay well
that is obviously not true it is a
shrine to freedom way you can tell it's
a shrine to freedom is because of all
the text on the memorial it's all
phraseology from the Declaration of
Independence talking about freedom a
great contradiction of Thomas Jefferson
as a human being is that he was a man
who held very high ideals but did not
abide by them which is a sin common to
humanity doesn't mean that Jefferson
didn't treat his slaves with unique evil
his treatment of Sally Hemings mean he
literally fathered children with his own
slave and then kept them in slave I mean
that's an act of great evil you don't
have to ignore any of that to recognize
that again for the thousandth time when
you build monuments to people who are
not building monuments to their cruelty
as a general rule you're building
monuments to the stuff they did that was
good you don't build the monuments
someone because you believe everything
they ever did was good you build the
monument to somebody because of the
thing they did that was good that is the
point
but according to this this guy who no
one cared about until five seconds ago
when he claims ancestry to Jefferson
which I assume is true now if he gets a
piece in The New York Times talking
about how it's time to take down the
Jefferson Memorial he says the memorials
a shrine to a man who during his
lifetime on more than six hundred slaves
had at least six children with one of
them Sally Hemings it's a shrine to a
man who famously wrote that all men are
created equal in the Declaration of
Independence and yet never did make did
much to make those words come true well
I mean he did do some to make those
words come true namely the founding of
the United States that was instrumental
in the tearing down of the institution
of slavery in the United States the
words he wrote in the Declaration of
Independence or invoke not just by
Abraham Lincoln to stop slavery in the
United States they were invoked by
Frederick Douglass to question why the
promises had not been extended to black
Americans they were invoked by Booker T
Washington they were invoked by Martin
Luther King jr. the idea that he did
nothing to end slavery is simply not
true he did nothing in his own life to
end slavery with regard from himself but
the principles he established which is
the reason the monuments they're not for
his personal life okay there were the
principles that he established were a
maybe the most important most important
philosophical
brick hurled through the window of
slavery in the United States so to
pretend that that makes no difference is
simply ridiculous
he says I'm the sixth-generation great
grandson of a slave owner my cousins
from Sally Hemings family are also the
great grandchildren of a slave owner the
difference is that our great-grandfather
owned their great gram there yes we get
it
we get it
I will also point out that when he says
that we should preserve Monticello
because you'll learn the history of
Jefferson at Monticello anytime he wants
us to tear down much like I don't know
why the mighty men should stand at all
right we are told by this guy by Lucian
Truscott a fourth hey Jefferson never
seen anything Penn slavery so why do we
even have a monument to him in
Monticello why are we preserving his
family his family memorial over a
month's chello that shouldn't be there
either the bottom line is that once the
door is open to people making a name for
themselves off a particular point of
view that happens to not like America
and that door does not close for quite a
while okay so all of this of course is
incredibly counterproductive none of it
helps the country forward you imagine
that President Trump could take
advantage of some of this and in fact
the speech they gave over the weekend at
Mount Rushmore was quite good on this
right he points out that the history of
America is good that our heroes are
worth remembering and that and that we
should not be tearing down statues of
Washington and Jefferson and no point as
he mentioned the Confederate flag and no
points as he mentioned Confederate
generals at no point does he get into
sort of the dicey areas of racial
controversy in the United States he
instead talks about the great universal
principles upon which the United States
was founded so naturally that means
within 48 hours he's tweeting about
stuff that completely undermines
everything that he said at Mount
Rushmore again Trump without Twitter is
somewhere near 50% in the approval
ratings Trump with Twitter is at 38% in
the approval rating he needs to stop
this he needs to stop it not only cuz
it's bad for the country but also on a
personal survival level as a politician
it is bad for him the president spent
the last 48 hours tweeting about Bubba
Wallace and NASCAR and renaming sports
teams he tweeted out has Bubba Wallace
apologized to all of those great NASCAR
drivers and officials who came to his
aid stood by his side and willing to
sacrifice everything for him only to
find out the whole thing was just
another hoax that and flag decision has
caused lowest ratings ever so there he
is defending a confederate flag against
the supposed predations of NASCAR and
going after Bubba Wallace in a
controversy that ended two weeks ago and
in which it turns out the Bubba Wallace
actually ended up making a pretty good
statement about how he was happy that it
didn't turn out to be a news and he was
glad the people showed solidarity with
him Hey look what is the president doing
here and the answer is he's not doing
anything he's boardings on the toilet
I'm sorry there is no forty chess game
here that's all that's happening the
president is bored he's on the toilet
he's watching Fox and Friends on the TV
and he's tweeting and it's all this
they tweeted about the renaming of
sports teams it they named teams out of
strength not weakness but now the
Washington Redskins and Cleveland
Indians to fabled sports sports
franchises look like they're going to be
changing their names in order to be
politically correct Indians like
Elizabeth Warren must be very angry
right now okay I'll admit that's funny
but it is also true it is this is it's
like the message that you're going for
he goes to Mount Rushmore and he gives
what should be a pretty easy unifying
message and then immediately he decides
to jump into sort of hot topics of the
day
over on the view and it's like this is
this is not not useful not useful okay
meanwhile there are actual serious
issues going on in the country and again
the president could be running against
the left on these issues particularly
the crime surge it turns out that the
vast black lives matter push to defund
the police has some pretty damned
horriffic consequences all over the
country and major cities we'll get to
that in just one second first or home
more than usual these days it's still
hard to keep a close eye on things more
deliveries means a lot of boxes left
unattended and in LA particularly we've
had a spate of people going around in
stealing boxes out of mail boxes or off
of fronts tubes well you can actually
hand that footage over to the police and
you can tell when somebody is doing that
because you are notified as soon as
someone is on your front stoop as long
as you have ring-ring gives you
protection at every corner video
doorbells let you answer the door and
check in on your home anytime and keep
an eye on your doorstep and speaks to
delivery people when you can't come to
the door without our security cameras
you can check in on every part of your
house and never miss a moment smart
lighting brightens up blind spots make
sure you always come home to a brightly
lit house full home security systems
give you everything you need to protect
your family
pets and property you get a special
offer on the ring welcome kit when you
go to ring comm slash Bend and welcome
kit includes the ring video doorbell 3
and the chime Pro that's all you need to
start building that ring of custom
security for your home today just go to
ring comm so I spend ring calm / man I
feel much more secure because I have
ring devices all over my house and keep
track of my crazy kids so when they're
trying to hurl themselves
bodily into dangerous areas I can go out
and stop them also and keep track of
what's going on outside my house no
matter where I am in the country which
is a great comfort to me during this
time go check them out at ring accom
slash man you will feel safer because
you will be safer ringing calm / man
that is ring calm / then you mean well
it turns out that all of this it's all
fun and games until people start getting
shot
so the whole sort of capitalization of
the black lives matter movement the
attempt to turn the the cause into a
business and then into a racket the
message still is promulgated and this is
the danger hey this is what I was saying
before about these short-term interests
of corporations not really meshing with
their long-term interests there's been a
critique of the left and some of the
populist right for a long time with
regard to corporations the corporation's
very often are looking at the bottom
line for like the next two weeks but
they're not looking at the bottom line
for the next 20 years because there's
turnover of corporations and there's
some studies that show that that is the
case with regards to particular
decisions overall typically people are
kind of looking down the road at what's
going on in the country but there's one
area where corporations are absolutely
helpless when it comes to looking down
the road and that is when there is
internal and external clamor about what
corporations are doing and that means
that when corporations are assaulted
from all sides about how that recordable
it's sponsoring hate speech on Facebook
and so they pull their money because
they're afraid of standing up for
themselves or when they are told
just sponsor diversity training and
we'll leave you alone they think
themselves okay well is the brand hit
really worth it okay here's the problem
they are not taking into account the
full weight of what's going to come on
the other end of the of the supplication
what's gonna happen after these
corporations are bowed to the pressure
is that there will be more pressure
it'll be more pressure and the messages
they are promulgating undermine the very
system that does allow them to operate
safely and securely so you will see Coca
Cola pull its ads from Facebook the
hessed of left-wing social media
pressure groups or attempting to to get
Coca Cola to disassociate from free
speech platforms right and then
coca-cola will have to move out of
Atlanta because coca-cola is going to be
in a city that is it has more crime
right these are all connected there is a
connection here between caving to causes
and actually undermine the system itself
and this is where corporations are not
taking into account the future in
corporations think that if they just
feed the alligator a little bit then
capitalism will always win capitalism
will always win well that's true up
until the point when the message is that
the corporation's themselves have been
sponsoring ends up destroying the system
within which they operate and that's the
cleverness I will say that is clever on
the part of some of the quote
anti-racist crowd I say quote
anti-racist because their definition of
an type
isn't anti-racism it's a complete
rewriting of the term as we've talked
about it basically means tear down the
system their idea is let's pressure
corporations into basically adopting our
sloganeering and then we'll use that
sloganeering to tear down the systems by
which the corporations get to operate in
fact by which all of American capitalism
that's top rate so all we have to do is
pressure them on this one soft point
I'll stick the knife in right here and
then it will cave to us and the air will
go out of the balloon and then we'll
collapse the system around them because
we'll actually turn them into a
loudspeaker against the system it allows
them to operate in free unmitigated
fashion you can see this most clearly
when it comes to crime so you've seen
you know the white woke left in these
major cities across the country
basically caving in to defund the police
movement because they figure okay well
you know what I live in a pretty safe
area what if we just you know let's
focus in the call for fighting police
brutality sounds pretty good
defunding the police doesn't sound as
good but you know maybe if we go along
with it and everything will calm down a
little bit and maybe just maybe it'll
work me now the system upon which you
get to spend all of your time protesting
because you live in a rich secure
wonderful free America that starts to
disappear too because the first
predicate for a successful civilization
is a certain sustainable level of law
and order and that is disappearing very
very quickly the crime is surging in
major cities around the United States
unfortunately Michael Snyder at the
economic collapse blog he says what we
are witnessing all over the country
right now is incredibly sad in the
aftermath of the tragic death of George
Floyd it would have been wonderful to
see the entire nation unite behind an
effort to make our society less violent
more just and peaceful instead we've
seen a tremendous explosion of violence
and lawlessness that doesn't seem likely
to end anytime soon
violent crime rates are surging in major
city after major city the 4th of July
weekend was particularly bad at least 41
people were hit by gunfire in New York
City during the holiday weekend this
continues a trend we have seen
throughout the first half of 2020
according to figures released by the
NYPD
for the first six months of this year
there were 176 murders an increase of
23% on the 143 killed during the same
period last year the number of shooting
victims has gone up 51% to 616 this year
in June alone there were 250 shootings
compared to 97 in the same month last
year month-on-month burglaries are up
119 percent
car thefts are up 48 percent those are
obviously
horrendous horrendous numbers and things
are getting worse in Chicago to at least
67 people were hit by gunfire in the
Windy City over the July 4th weekend
including 13 people were shot to death
nine of the weekend's victims were
miners two children died including a 14
year old boy
Philadelphia shootings are up 67%
victims of armed violence from 29%
homicides are up 25% law enforcement in
downtown Portland are under attack
consistently from members of an Tifa and
what we are watching right now is the
collapse of law and order in major
cities around the United States and by
the way the people who are damaged most
by this are black and brown people
according to Tom Windsor a reporter for
NBC News quote every single person who
has been shot in New York City this July
nearly a hundred in total has been a
member of M of the minority community
97% of shooting victims in June were
members of the city's minority
communities according to the NYPD chief
of crime control strategies Michael Lee
Petri told reporters yesterday all
murder victims in June all rather the
minority community the city's spike in
crime is now a bona fide trend homicides
are up 27% year-to-date running 11.3%
higher than they were five years ago
50% of the shootings have taken place in
just ten precincts those communities are
being overrun by a small percentage of
gang members of little regard for their
own life and no regard for their
community chicago's recent crime
fighting success has cratered a homicide
rate that has written Thursday that has
risen 34 percent this year compared to
last for a total of three hundred and
twenty four deaths over the last 28 days
compared to last year over the same
period
homicides rose 83% in Chicago 83% for
this reason you are seeing governor's in
red states starting to react the Georgia
Governor Brian Kemp has now deployed a
thousand National Guard troops to
Atlanta after the violent weekend in
Atlanta Americans are more and more
looking at Legion leaving larger cities
for suburban towns because this is what
happens the white woke liberals they go
along with this stuff but then because
the white woke liberals are rich enough
to spend their days not worried about
what happens to poorer people who are
victimized by violence when the violence
reaches their front door they're like oh
you know what this is a bad place to
live I'm leaving
according to the hill a perfect storm of
factors make the decision to leave at
major cities like New York very obvious
many are moving too small
north of the five boroughs for upstate
counties have seen an incredible surge
in real estate demand while the rest of
the New York market is cratering oh who
could have perceived that all of the
woke policies pursued by black lives
matter our counts are productively
pushing people to leave these cities and
the people disproportionately who can
afford to leave the cities namely the
people who are paying for the tax base
in these cities but don't worry it's
really all about the cause guys remember
it's all about the cause it's not about
it's not a media racket it's all about
the cause now how does this get
justified really seriously how does this
get justified is the big question
because when you see a tremendous uptake
in violence when you see people who are
being shot and in New York City a
hundred percent members minority
communities what do you see that how can
you possibly justify causes like defund
the police or let's not talk about the
problem of the inner city violence which
by the way is what this is I mean we're
watching in these cases minority a
minority violence is in white cops going
into these inner cities and killing
people that's not what's happening here
how do we justify that we justify that
by blinking ourselves we sure because
the narrative must live this is how you
know it's a racket it's a racket because
the narrative has to live even if people
have to die to preserve the narrative
that's a racket there's no other way to
describe it we're gonna get to the media
racket the Democratic racket it is a
racket here we're gonna get to it in
just one second first the quintessential
American Dream is owning and building a
successful business in freedom an
opportunity of being your own boss is a
major major thing right I've always
wanted to be my own boss now I'm lucky
enough to be my own boss but if you're a
business owner you know that there are a
lot of moving parts it's very easy to
get lost in the shuffle and for
information to get lost in the shuffle
here's something you definitely can't
let get lost in the shuffle I'm talking
about invoices right you finally you do
a service for somebody who invoice them
six months later you remember Ojai
invoice that guy and then I just
completely forgot about it because I had
made a Word document on my computer
printed out and handed it to the guy
that is not the way you should do
business instead our friends over at
blink Sale built an invoicing software
that helps you stay on top of your money
and keep track of everything in one
place so you can stop sending those
nagging emails to get paid for your work
with blink sale you can send beautiful
custom branded invoices and estimates in
seconds you can stay on top of your
outstanding invoices you can let your
customers and clients easily pay your
invoices online you even get instant
notifications when a customer opens your
invoice so you'll actually know if
they're just avoiding paying you we're
get about using
voice templates are stressing about
coordinating a bunch of different
software programs Blaisdell takes care
of it soup to nuts for you so you can
actually get paid for the business that
you have done and make your business a
success as an added bonus blink sale is
giving away ten bucks to five hundred
daily wire fans here's how to get it but
a blink sale calm sir your 14-day free
trial
create your first invoice of ten bucks
and activate an online payment option
stripe or PayPal send the invoice to
daily wire at blink sale comma get paid
or $10 the first 500 people to send an
invoice for 10 bucks to daily wire at
bling sale comm will get their invoice
paid by blink sale limit of one per
person pretty pretty solid deal just to
try out a service you really have any
way South wasting your time invoicing
trebling sale for free @ blink sale calm
/ Ben that is bli nks a le comm / pen
link sale calm / Ben go check them out
right now okay coming up we're gonna get
to how you know this is a racket and how
this being played is a racket people are
dying but doesn't matter
we can't pay attention to the dead
people pay no attention to the bodies in
the corner we have a narrative to
promote here we have a narrative to
promote we're gonna get to that in just
one second first if you're not already a
daily why remember you really should
consider getting a reader's pass to
daily work on it is a great value for
only 3 bucks a month when you sign up
you get that first month for only 99
cents you also get access to our mobile
app articles ad free and access to
exclusive editorials like my latest anti
racism crusade seeks to eradicate
everything we share anti racism isn't
scare quotes right there as it should be
because it's a term of art that is being
used and misappropriated so if you
haven't checked out the readers pass
already pattern over to daily wear comm
and sign up for just one dollar go check
it out right now you're listening some
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so these black lives do matter okay the
people who are being shot in cities
around the United States again aren't
disproportionately of color right
they're disproportionately black
specifically they're disproportionately
brown black there are some people who
are Hispanic being shot but
disproportionally these are black people
who are being shot those lives matter
too there's some heartbreaking video
they came out from Chicago where an 11
year old boy was murdered and the
grandfather was on TV and he said it
seems like too many people black lives
matter only they only matter when a cop
pulls the trigger otherwise you don't
give two solid damns about it and he is
exactly right about this that's exactly
right because the narrative is about the
narrative and the nerd is about tearing
down the system the narrative from the
black lives matter organization and from
the media about black lives matter is
not just about police brutality it's
about the idea that America is
systemically racist that all problems
that are experienced in the United
States can be chalked up to the system
itself and that there is what we should
just pay no attention to the far bigger
problem the far bigger threat to black
life in the United States because all
violence in the United States is
informational virtually all right
meaning white skill-wise black hills
blacks kill blacks Latinos kill Latinos
on a statistical level that is the
reality that means that the far greater
threat to black life in the United
States than the cops are criminals who
share the race of the of the victim
right again true cross racially true in
every race but we're not allowed to pay
attention to that it's a black person
killing another black person and it does
matter if the kid is the kid it doesn't
matter we're not gonna know the name of
this dead 11 year old from the media
because that 11 year old doesn't matter
i Tamir rice matters because Tamir rice
was 12 years old and was shot by the
police in disputed circumstances in
which he was unfortunately killed in a
horrific situation where he had saw the
front off of a BB gun so it looked like
a regular gun and the cops mistook him
we all know that name it's a terrible
terrible situation no one is gonna know
the name of this 11 year old because his
death does not back the narrative that
the greatest threat to black life in the
United States is coming from white
supremacists and an evil white
supremacist systems here is the
grandfather of this eleven-year-old
everybody just saying they're just high
tide of the shootings in the community
everybody's running around here thinking
they're easy toting dope sucking
psychopathic killer machines and they
just destroying lives but we're
protesting for months for weeks
saying black lives matter black lives
matter black minds matter it seemed like
only when a police officer shoot a black
person what about all the black on black
crime that's happening in the community
does he not have the credibility to say
that his grandson just got shot by the
wise in Washington DC not in Chicago you
know the 11-year old boy was identified
as Devon McNeil you try to remember the
name because of me you don't care I mean
you're not gonna pay any attention to
Devon McNeil just as they paid no
attention to the literally dozens of
young black kids who probably been
killed this year in major cities across
the United States I believe there were
four or five killings of young black
people across the United States I
mention wife fourth weekend alone none
of them by cops but we saw the killings
of two black miners in in Seattle chop
you don't know their names right the
media narrative is that America is to
blame for all of this and that personal
responsibility at no level can be
applied to a problem in which personal
responsibility is required right here's
the grandfather saying even you a bunch
of young people who are treating
themselves as Ozzy toting killing
machines that's a problem the media
won't talk about that problems that
problem doesn't matter you know mix is
perfectly clear the scam sound lemon
makes it's perfectly clear so Don Lemon
head Terry Crews on Terry Crews pointed
out and it seems to me that if you say
black lives matter that really should
include all black lives matter
so I'm old enough to remember when if
somebody said black lives matter and you
said all I was matter this meant that
you were bad why did this mean you were
bad because the category all includes
black right that is just a logical fact
ok the category all includes all which
would include black people as well as
white people as long as banning people
so all lives matter was just a
recognition that black lives matter just
the same way and all other lives matter
this was considered insufficiently woke
because if you said all lives matter
what you were failing to recognize is
the special threat that existed to black
lives from the white system now I do not
actually believe that the cops posed a
special threat to black lives in the
United States because statistically
speaking they do not actually pose a
greater threat to black lives in the
United States there's zero statistical
evidence that police disproportionately
shoot black people in the United States
that evidence does not exist okay so
even putting that aside but even
assuming that you believe that there is
racism miasmatic systemic racism and
institutional racism brought to bear on
black people
so black lives matter you would think
would include all black lives matter but
here's where you're wrong
according to down lemon he actively says
this according to down lemon if somebody
says to you black lives matter and you
say you're right all black lives matter
right now just all odds not we're not
talking about whites when I talking
about Latinos now we're saying all black
lives matter so it matters when a black
kid is shot by the cops and it matters
just as much when as is far more common
a black kid is shot by another black
person if you say that that's bad so you
can't say let's hope apparently the
category black lives does not include
all black lives it only includes some
black lives and some lemon says this out
loud which is very very wild rights
especially while because he's lying in
two ways one black lives matter should
include all black lives obviously and if
we and and this is the discussion the
media wish to avoid obviously if the
media we're going to discuss the
priority of saving black lives that
would require them to talk about
something beyond the evil of the cops in
fact you'll require more cops not fewer
cops but the mean II don't want to talk
about that right that undercuts the
narrative and so they would rather
overtly say but not all black lives
matter right they would rather say that
and acknowledge the reality which is the
solution to violence against black
people is the same as the solution to
violence against all people generally
which is you need more law enforcement
not less law enforcement alright so Don
Lemon doesn't want to say that so what
you're gonna hear in this clip is Don
Lemon explicitly say that if you say to
somebody black lives matter and they say
back to you all black lives matter
they're avoiding the point which is
police brutality he's lying in that way
he's also lying when he said because
you'll hear him saying in this clip he
will say that black lives matter is only
about police brutality that is clearly
not true it is clearly not true okay if
you've been watching what's been going
on in the United States we've been told
that if you loot a store that is part of
the black lives matter movement because
it is unbridled rage against the system
that's not just about police brutality
police brutality is one symptom but the
bigger problem is systemic institutional
racism right the racism that's out there
in the air aerosol eyes just like
coronavirus rights just out there and
you can't avoid it and it affects you
even if you don't know you have it right
so don't give me that black lives matter
was just about police brutality
when it was just about police brutality
I was on board when it was about police
brutality I was talking on the show
about how qualified immunity might need
to be curbed in certain ways I was
talking about better data sharing right
we were all on board with that and then
the bill died in the Senate and nobody's
mentioned it again ever which suggests
that this is all
it is all a racket on the part of the
media members doesn't mean everybody
who's marching knows that it's a scam on
the part of the media members but it is
okay it's a scam when you when you hear
Don Lemon again gaslighting you by
saying black lives matter it was always
just about police brutality really then
why are we talking about tearing down
statues really then what exactly does
black lives matter have to do with the
69 theme project right if it's just
about police brutality then what the
hell are what is this broader
conversation that down lemon is
promoting each and every night on his
show why is it that the black lives
matter organization does not restrict
itself to police brutality as Terry
Crews points out the black lives matter
organization is a neo-marxist
organization talks about restructuring
systems destroying it says this on his
website destroying the atomic family and
free Palestine so they do not actually
limit their priorities to black lives
matter so it down lemon really means
that there's only one narrative he wants
to promote any narrative that is
consonant with the message that America
is to blame for all evils and that white
supremacy is to blame for everything
that happens in the United States that's
worth discussing if a black person kills
another black person in the inner city
and that does not matters who down lemon
apparently that is not worth discussing
he says you can form a you can form
a committee to talk about that except
that black people are dying in real-time
in major cities around the United States
at an extraordinary rate because of
exactly the policies that are being
pursued by people like Don Lemon on
national television so now it's a little
relevant is it not now would be a good
time to discuss it not form a separate
committee hey here's Don Lemon saying
that when you say all black lives matter
you're neglecting that we're only
talking about a certain subset of black
lives which should beg the question or
at least raise the question why why
here's some I mean just really I mean
it's a clarifying and wonderful clip the
black lives matter movement was started
because it was talking about police
brutality if you want an all black lives
matter movement that talks about gun
violence in communities including you
know black communities then start that
movement with that name but that's not
what black lives matter is about it's
not an all-encompassing so if you're
talking about if someone started moving
that said cancer matters and then
someone comes and said why aren't you
talking about HIV it's not the same
thing we're talking about cancer black
lives matters about criminality and a
and about criminal-justice it's not
about what happens in in communities
when it comes to crime black-on-black
crime people who live near each other
black people kill each other
same as whites 80 some percent of white
people are killed by white people sure
because of proximity it's the same thing
with black people it happens in every
single neighborhood but that isn't again
I'm not saying that's not important that
there's those kids die but it's a
movement okay step he says it's nothing
it's not important those kids die but
it's a different movement no it's not
okay so now black lives matter means
whatever Don Lemon says black lives
matter means it started off as police
brutality then it moved on to defund the
police then it moved on to tear down all
the statues and implicate the entire
American system then it moved on to
Independence Day in Mount Rushmore and
now Dunham is like no no no we were just
talking about police brutality stop
mentioning the fact that a
disproportionate number of young black
people are being killed by other young
black people in inner cities which by
the way is even much larger threat to
black life in the United States stop
talking about it by the way his analogy
completely fails if you had a if you had
he suggests in that clip if you had a
group called cancer matters and then
somebody else had HIV matters that that
would be a change of topic that's true
because what you are talking about the
nelem there is cancer okay the noun here
is black lives
that means all black lives you
equivalents if you're gonna make an
analogy would be you start a group
called cancer matters and someone says
prostate cancer matters correct this
falls within you can't subcategory of
cancer
you idiots I mean that is that is
clearly what so I have a lot of
suspicion of terms that expand and
contract at will in order to promote a
certain narrative and that's what you're
watching right here because for a lot of
people in the media this is not about
saving black lives for a lot of people
in the media this is not about making
life in America better for a lot of
people in media it's about pushing
causes that they like regardless of the
consequences consequences be damned and
don't worry you can always blame
somebody else Chicago Mayor Lori
Lightfoot was asked about increased
violence in her city and she's blaming
freaking coronavirus she's blaming Cove
8:19 which by the way you should see a
decline in violence in your city when
you when you relegate everyone to their
homes you shouldn't see an increase in
murder in your city when everyone is
forced to go to their houses and wait
out a pandemic but here she's blaming
copa90 not home not her own crappy
policy what is happening right now all
these forces are coming
together at the same time and making it
very difficult the ecosystem of Public
Safety that isn't just law enforcement
but as local community base they too
have really been hit hard by kovat and
are now just kind of coming back online
and getting their footing oh it was
Colvin who's called it by the way mayor
he shot Lance bottoms in Atlanta where a
child was shot over the weekend an
eight-year-old child we talked out
yesterday on the show was shot to death
because she has allowed the area around
the Wendy's where Rashad Brooks a
criminal was shot by the police after
grabbing a Taser off a cop shooting the
cop trying to shoot another cop with the
Taser and then was shot people have
taken over that area near the Wendy's
and they've set up sort of a pair of
military zone and somebody tried to
drive through with an eight-year-old
child in the back and people shot the
kid to death now he shall and spot him
who's being vetted for VP in the
Democratic Party as she presides over a
city in a state of collapse
she suggests that President Trump is to
blame for the increased violence in her
city we talked about systemic racism and
the trauma in the anxiety and all these
things that are happening in our
communities and it is convergence and
and I hate to use the word a perfect
storm
but it's where we are in this country
right now and you think about the
leadership or the lack thereof that we
have coming from the highest office in
the land
you're the mayor you're the mayor of the
city it's the national leadership you're
the mayor of the city mayor of the city
she's the mayor like you don't get to do
that come on come on so Trump has now
become like systemic racism he could
he's blamable for everything he's the
god of the gaps at this point I can't
explain my why my own governance is a
absolute garbage my police forces are
walking out on me because I keep
maligning them I can't explain any of it
so you know instead what I'm really
gonna talk about is Trump Trump from
from from Trump remember the all-purpose
excuse bad orange man orange man bad bad
orange bad orange man meanwhile by the
way he showed Lance bottoms it comes out
has Kovan 19 that's it she says that she
is not symptomatic but she does have
koban 19 and some yes she did a 10
protest without a mask that was the
thing that happened she says she has
tested positive for
Rhona virus speaking of copán 19 i'm
gonna give you quick joven 19 update
here cuz even talked about it in a
couple days and the media misinformation
here is truly astonishing
so NBC is reporting that Cova 19 cases
are skyrocketing amidst the celebrations
okay I would just like to note this
started directly when the protests
started you can look at the timeline the
cases began to jump right at the
beginning of June what else was
happening right at the beginning of June
not the reopening the reopening in these
states began in early May when the when
did the spike happen it happened content
with the protests which makes sense
because the cases that we are seeing are
largely mild they're not leading to
death
in the same way there among young people
here is NBC suggesting that it really is
you know random closets it couldn't be
that couldn't be a protest or anything
syncope in nineteen cases are
skyrocketing there's two lies the media
are telling about this one is that the
rates of death are inevitably going to
increase here but yet we're waiting and
like I mean maybe it'll happen maybe it
won't when you make a prediction and
then the prediction doesn't come true
for like a full month at a certain point
you have to start wondering like there
will come an expiration date I think
it's probably a week and a half away
where if the death rates have not
skyrocketed people are just gonna be
like what was supposed to happen here
because yesterday reported number of
deaths 378 in the United States last
month last Monday reported number of
deaths in the United States in the
United States 366 okay so in other words
we've basically been in flatline you can
look at the chart it looks like a bell
curve and it kind of on the other side
of the of the steep hill is a sort of
slow descent okay but we've been at a
plateau for a while here now the deaths
continued to decrease so the case is
increased
that's decrease so why number one is
that inevitably to four we know we know
that the deaths will follow it'll be
just like New York we've been hearing
this seriously from members of the media
it's gonna be new 10 New York's all over
the country no it probably is not going
to be like that there are multiple
reasons why it's not gonna be like that
which I'll get to in just a second that
is why number one is that the is that
the cases are skyrocketing before the
deaths will follow you don't know that
number two UI is that the vast uptick in
cases cannot be attributed in any way to
great social justice protests instead
they have to be attributed solely to
backyard barbecues and reopening and
evil rounds of Santa san
evil Doug Ducey in Arizona nothing Gavin
Newsom in California who's also
experiencing a major uptick
because Gavin Newsom is good because
he's a demo
but all the other Republican governors
are very bad so those are the two lies
that you are being told there was NBC
News doing some panic porn coronavirus
concerns not enough to keep everyone
home this holiday weekend Myrtle Beach
brimming with visitors Fire Island in
New York lit up with people and at this
Michigan Lake party attendees packed
together and no visible masks for many
Americans this fourth of July felt a
little foreign with shuttered shores and
scaled back fireworks though it is
disappointing but it is understandable
but even though safety steps couldn't
stop a furious kovat surge this weekend
Florida South Carolina and Texas among
the states notching new daily records
okay so obviously we should be worried
about the case numbers test numbers and
a few things to note about the test
numbers one the tests have increased the
positivity rates have increased in some
cases you're seeing people double tested
because does it actually I reflected in
places like Florida apparently is that
if you get tested and you test positive
you test again to make sure it's not
false positive for example and both
those cases get reported but even with
that said there's obviously an uptick in
number of cases the question is is it
going to overwhelm the hospital system
and are people going into hospitals
dying and those are two separate
questions is it over long the hospital
systems so far the answer is no so far
the answer is no the media keeps saying
that Texas is overwhelmed and then like
a day later the head of the Texas House
will be like nah we got flex capacity
we're still doing in Texas I believe
they're still doing elective surgeries
which means that those beds are being
filled by people who do not have kovat
in fact it Arizona as of yesterday the
inpatients bed in use are basically the
same as they were a month ago right so
it's not as though the ICUs are being
completely overwhelmed in in Arizona
we're not to that point yet we're not
being overwhelmed in the state of Texas
just last week the heads of all the
Texas major hospitals in Houston they
were saying we're not overwhelmed in the
same way in the ICU zazz
New York also worth noting that the
hospitalizations today right
hospitalizations are rising but the
outcome of hospitalizations has
dramatically decreased in the United
States dramatically decreased in the
United States if you look for example at
the hospital census and the number of
people who are dying deaths as a
percentage of Kogut hospitalizations
from 5 to 12 days ago excluding Florida
there there's a good
chart that I've seen on this this chart
shows that the deaths as a percentage of
kovat hospitalizations from five to
twelve days ago which is usually the
period rate get hospitalized and then
for gonna die you're dead within five to
twelve days in the hospital after we've
gone on an ICU bed and on a ventilator
or something the deaths as a percentage
of kovat hospitalizations from five to
twelve days ago in early April deaths as
a percentage were pretty high like
really pretty high like up to something
like fifteen percent something like
fifteen percent now or at least at least
well above the summer see I'm sorry is
somewhere between five and ten percent
was it was where it was now the
percentage is close to zero it's very
very like the vast vast majority people
who are going into hospitals are not
dying from this thing and that is
because large number of reduced severity
hospitalizations people are coming in
they've kovat having a little bit of
trouble breathing but they're probably
gonna be okay and we're putting them in
the hospital just out of an abundance of
caution patients are much more willing
to seek treatment now because it was a
while back that if you were going to get
kovat you just weren't going into the
hospital because you were afraid that
they were then going to put you in
events and then you were going to never
see your family again so people were
just staying home and then healing up at
home and fewer hospitalizations are
becoming deaths and ever so again we're
we're waiting maybe the wave is gonna
come but if you look at the chart from
several months ago as far as tests and
hospitalizations and deaths what you see
is that the hospitalizations go like
this about two weeks later the deaths go
like that right they really they really
parallel each other very strongly right
now what you're saying in
hospitalizations is this right it's
rising and deaths are going like that
that start tailing off so the two have
completely uncoupled maybe they start
coupling again but not clear that that
is the case Miami Dade's mayor says that
actually you know you guys keep talking
about the number of positive cases he
says listen these states covet counts
might be underestimated by a factor of
10 right so it is quite possible that we
have ten times the number of people with
coronavirus out there in the state which
is both good news and bad news right
means the spread is basically
uncontrolled it also means that deaths
have not risen so that should be
something that it's actually worthy of
celebrating and this is by the way
what's happened in Sweden I mean up take
a number of tests and a real down taking
the number of deaths the same thing is
happening in Israel where there's been
up taking the number of tests and the
deaths are basically stagnant so in in
or
world the media would be trumpeting this
is some cautious optimism right yep you
saying like you should still be careful
out there wear a mask when you're out
and about but the fact that you're
getting this thing means you're not
dying that's a very good piece of news
right instead we are seeing people
getting more alarmist about this thing
when it seems like the virus is becoming
less deadly at least as a matter of
treatment and at least as a percentage
of tests that are coming back positive
here is the mayor of Miami pointing out
that the number of cases might be way
higher than we even know at this point
we did a medical study here in Miami
Dade two months ago that we knew over
200,000 people had already tested
positive if we took the the positive
rate that we put that out 200,000 people
would test the positive to the antibody
so the official number that you see
especially Miami day we have about
40,000 we know it's way under counted
it's probably by a factor of 10 and I
expect the same thing in the state of
Florida so the more testing you do the
more people you're gonna find that have
it again at this point I would think
that the the rule should actually be
cautious optimism not this extraordinary
pessimism that's being pushed it's also
being pushed about the schools right
there's this idea that if you open the
schools everyone's gonna die it's crazy
how can you open the schools I mean the
American Academy of Pediatrics said you
should basically open the schools at
this point my kids are not dying from
this thing the death rates for young
children is lower for this than it is
for the flu and yet Florida's being bad
at about the ears because the Florida
Education Commission required all
Florida school districts to reopen
campuses in August hey Rhonda stances
points the sound is being ripped for
right he said the death rate for young
people is near zero but this means he
doesn't care enough so this is once
again become our stupid normal American
conversation about how much you care and
not about the data not about the facts
how much you care Rhonda stances points
out the death rate is close to zero for
young people and and he gets ripped for
it obviously clearly we've we viewed a
series from the beginning in January
when we were monitoring it but at the
same time when you hear news about cases
I just think that should be put in the
proper context and perspective that the
number one age for cases in Florida is
21 and if you're 21 and you don't have
significant comorbidities your your
fatality rate is pretty much zero where
act correct which is one of the reasons
why they're trying to reopen the
schools but apparently we got to keep
the schools closed if in two weeks
there's not a significant uptick in
death then it is perfectly obvious this
was not cautioned by the media this was
just an attempt to panic and I'm I'm
willing to wait it out but I'm not
willing to wait it out forever I'm gonna
take exactly the same perspective on
this that I took at the very beginning
when I suggested that let's let the
lockdowns work okay you want to say that
the death is inevitably going to come
maybe it is but never to be better have
an end date because inevitable doesn't
mean ten years from now and it doesn't
mean six months from now it doesn't even
mean a month from now the spike began at
the beginning of June we are now in
early July
so that spike doesn't happen soon you're
gonna have to start questioning some of
the experts about why it is that the
virus seems to either have gotten milder
or is killing fewer people overall
alrighty we are going to be back
tomorrow with a lot more content you
should go subscribe over it daily we're
calm while you're at it go pick up a
copy of my new book a little bit early
how to destroy America in three easy
steps
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer Austin Stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
SCI events audio is mixed by Mike Cora
Mina hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
Colin Kapernick milks more money out of
fake oppression the LM ignores black
lives lost and Harvard charges $50,000 a
year for correspondence courses
check it out on a Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you